voilà ah le grand
assumer tout de suite les Guignols
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes l'an 2023 et 3 télévisions
bonsoir Harrison Ford a reçu une palme
d'honneur le comédien américain de 80
ans s'est montré très touché par cette
distinction je vous propose de l'écouter
[Applaudissements]
vous entendez cette musique celle de
John Williams je voudrais une réponse
sincère est-ce que vous êtes un peu
fatigué de l'entendre depuis toutes ces
années
[Musique]
partout je vais
essayer
[Musique]
d'opération
ferme les yeux et ferme ta gueule
[Musique]
attendez excusez-moi je suis désolé
c'est un direct mais j'ai pas de piano
est-ce que je peux avoir du piano oui
désolé mais je joue je joue sans piano
est-ce que vous l'entendez mon prénom à
qui je dois demander le piano
le son est prévenu nous on l'entendait
[Musique]
une chose mystérieuse
je suis désolé
j'arrive pas
je propose de regarder à quoi ça
ressemble
moi ça devrait marcher quand c'est
classe c'est tout de suite là quand je
dis à quoi ça ressemble
est-ce que Juliette
est-ce que vous permettez ah bon je me
rapprocher Juliette
Juliette le temps de régler ça est-ce
qu'on il y avait encore un bout
d'interview d'Anna Viola diffusé on le
diffuse on parle d'un navire et le temps
que le son se règle et on vient vers
vous dans une seconde à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci ça fait quelques semaines que je
ne l'ai pas vu
et en plus c'est quelqu'un qui boit bien
[Rires]
nous avons tous les deux
la bouteille quand nous déjeunons
d'imaginer que
une musique va aider un vin à évoluer
pendant plusieurs mois des enceintes
vont même être plongées dans ces grandes
cuves pour animer la fermentation et
nourrir les tanins
tout ce mieux très vivant va être
stimulé par la sonorité par les
vibrations harmonieuses que le quatuor
produit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le week-end vous êtes sur scène déjà à
l'école les profs le savent tout ça
comment ça se passe
d'abord c'est un secret puisque mon père
me demande de pas en parler moi je le
dirai à mes copines à partir de 15-16
ans
[Musique]
et la réaction des profs qu'il apprenne
c'est quoi pas terrible mon père est
convoqué chez le directeur il pense
qu'il me fait faire le tapin enfin
pourquoi est-ce qu'on me met à côté du
plus gros zizi d'Europe
et pas la plus jolie fille du monde
je sais mais je me serais pas faire
voilà s'il te plaît pour intimider les
agents de sécurité l'un des individus
des gaines sont portables et filme la
scène
le matin je me branche parce que c'est
notre projet et à cette époque là je
faisais la téléphonie rose aussi
une dizaine de sketches par jour et il
fallait quand on répondait au téléphone
jouer la scène quoi
bonjour je suis Samantha je suis hôtesse
de l'air tu m'as l'air très mignon toi
voilà c'était des histoires que tu
normalement aller jusqu'au bout de la
faire quoi
au début ça vous gênait les dialogues
dans les films de cul
en fait je suis pas je me suis pas mis
dans le porno à la base pour pour être
acteur et pas labiale
[Rires]
parce que je me mie qui a regardé des
films avec Ferrara donc je l'ai appelé
hier soir pendant encore
garder un peu c'est votre mari encore
oublié de sortir la poubelle ou je ne
sais quel autre truc insignifiant du
quotidien qui vous aurait saoulé
[Musique]
vous retrouver à côté de branches
infesté de fourmis rouges qui font de
vous leur 4h à côté d'un inconnu à poil
à côté d'un mec à poil que je connais
pas